now first one announcement if anyone
cares the crowded field of democratic
radical socialist just shrunk by one
governor jay Inslee he dropped out of
the race did anybody even know he was in
the race I think it's now former RNC
Chairman former White House chief of
staff Reince Priebus and Fox News
contributor Tammy Bruce you know let's
go through a little bit of sleepy creepy
crazy let's see his old wife Tammy if we
look at it that wasn't very encouraging
you know yeah you're gonna have to
swallow hard you know it's not good his
brain surgeon says no his brains okay
can't go to a 7-eleven or Dunkin Donuts
without a slight Indian accent bragging
his state was a slave state
that's just oh and then my favorite Oh
this is the first time ever you got an
African American that is bright
articulate and clean it's storybook or
poor kids are just as talented as white
kids and Joe 303 302 yeah yeah but
here's the thing that also I think
Americans should be concerned about and
Democrats should be appalled by that
he's actually in this position it is
clear he should not be and yet the
Democratic Party is so destroyed and
Barack Obama destroyed it in his
cultivation of a cult that they're
pushing this man to do it because they
do believe that he would have more of an
appeal than all the rest of their talent
so there's a point where it's becoming
embarrassing for this man to be in this
position
his wife clearly wants to support him
she obviously is also worried about the
party but they can't even push through
it on their own and I think that that
tells you everything you need to know
but then also that the Democrats
themselves it also highlights the
contempt they have for the American
people and for their own base that
there's no real interest in being there
for everyone in the country there's they
either they lie about who's a racist
they want to divide and conquer there
they're proposing things Bernie Sanders
the other day admitted when he was asked
at a town hall how much the Medicare for
all would cost he said oh I don't have
that
in my pocket nobody does we really don't
know they have no idea and yet they're
putting themselves in this position
because they believe their own bases
ignorant they believe the American
people are dumb and this is what they
have to offer the American people
I hope the Republicans understand this
because the Democrats are really turning
into a major problem for the American
people and then my favorite rides is has
common truth over facts but he's got
eight years of a record eight years of
economic policy failure the Iranian deal
eight years of foreign policy failure
nobody's even begun to talk about that
part well in the other problem that they
have a few of the campaign manager for
Joe Biden you've got to worry that these
gaffes aren't just a pattern a lot of
people are saying oh it's a pattern a
problem no the question is if this
pattern becomes it's an issue of mental
competence that is the issue that's
going to bring it right that already
happened isn't that happening yeah and I
think it is happening in the media I
think the media and some of the folks in
the media that want a more progressive
candidate they want an Elizabeth Warren
they want a Kamala Harris that this
they're gonna swarm over this issue
that's plaguing Joe Biden like like we
can't imagine here's the other problem
for the Democrats though President Trump
has has outmaneuvered the Democrats on
one of their signature issues which is
sentencing reform Elizabeth Warren's
talking about sentencing reform the only
problem they have is that the person
they actually have to run against
actually did it and did it more
favorably than any president in modern
history so they've got a huge problem
right now not to mention the fact that
Newt Gingrich wrote a book called real
change many years ago and the whole
premise was is that you need the frame
of these issues in such a way that 70
percent of the American people agree
with you on who doesn't agree with
moving the capital from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem every presidents promised it
Trump delivered it who doesn't who
didn't believe that the Iran deal was
bad maybe 30 percent liked it but said 7
good question this is what they're
facing who gets the nomination as of
tonight
Tammy well I tell you it won't be Joe
Biden when it comes to who the
establishment thinks I think they
believe Kamala Harris is gonna have it
we'll have to wait and see what happens
what do you think right I think I think
it's I think Biden will squeak through
but I would look out for Elizabeth
Warren I'm leaning a slight advantage
Elizabeth as of tonight thank you both